it's not that we have so little time but
that we lose so much Seneca said the
life we receive is not short but we make
it so the story on why I started working
12 hours beach day wasn't very
intentional I didn't just like wake up
one day and say like hey I'm going to
start working 12 hours from now on it
was around 1 and a half years ago I
started getting really deep into
personal development and
entrepreneurship and for better or worse
I usually have this pretty nasty habit
of getting like super obsessed over
things that I get into for as long as I
can remember back in high school that
wasn't a quinone it's hard for me I
remember like training and teaching five
to seven hours per day five or six days
per week and on top of that I were like
locked myself in my room and practice a
single guitar riff or guitar solo for
like ten hours straight so for me once I
saw the benefits of personal development
and business it was kind of just another
thing for me to obsess over so why would
I do this to myself like [ __ ] I'll be
going out and enjoying lying and
partying and going to bars all the time
you know Yolo right if that's still a
thing and when people hear that there
are other people out there that work
these long hours what did they usually
think of twelve hours of boring
monotonous life draining keep a court
where you have to like dick around to
have any fun but it's not really like
that for me after all I'm not just doing
this just for the sake of making money
and I think growth for the sake of
growth it's kind of ridiculous
probably the main reason that I work
these vlogging hours is that I've just
never found anything else that really
fulfills me as much as working towards
my dreams because if you think about it
I could spend every minute of that sweet
12 hours knowing that every single
little thing that I'm doing no matter
how big or small how complex or how
trivial is all contributing to me
hitting my goals and another main reason
is that I view it as my ethical
obligation
as much the society as I possibly can
and because money is just an exchange
for value the more money I make means
that the more people that I help the
more jobs that I create and the more
impact that I have we live in a world
where the playing field is as level as
it's ever been it may not be as level as
some people may want it but it's still
pretty level and you're not bound to the
caste or the social status that you're
born into and because of this potential
freedom that the world has never seen
before
aren't we obligated to make the most out
of it
and the other main reason that I choose
to work these long hours is more of a
selfish one contrary to my last point
it's not whether you like her or not
even though the playing field is as
level as it's ever been the world is
still a competitive place and in this
competitive world there's a statistical
advantage to you doing something like 12
hours per day seven days per week
compared to the average person that puts
in what may be like an hour per day
outside of their day-to-day routine
towards their goals and on that scale
alone you're already moving
theoretically 12 times faster than the
average person towards your goals what
takes people an entire year to
accomplish working an hour a day you'll
be able to accomplish that in 30 days
but that's also assuming that progress
and knowledge is linear you probably
already know about compound interest
where a penny doubled every single day
for 30 days rate comes out to a whopping
5.3 million dollars and I found the same
to be true for knowledge and progress as
do you learn more stuff your skills
start to stack on top of each other and
before you know it you built up all this
momentum and just like the penny your
progress starts to look like an
exponential curve and that's why all the
most successful self-made people out
there like Bill Gates and Elon Musk they
all work these ridiculously long hours
on their way up they don't work long
hours because they're successful they're
successful because they work these long
hours it's no surprise that this habit
that I built up has really contributed
to the company I run growing super fast
and this channel growing pretty
consistently as well but probably the
biggest perk that I've noticed it's just
a pure sense of accomplishment that you
feel at the end of a long day when you
end a long day and you look back up all
the little things that you accomplished
and you just know that she made the most
of the time that you had on this planet
for the day there's just no better
fulfilling feeling out there in the
world
and when I compare the fulfillment that
I get from doing this versus the things
that I used to enjoy like playing video
games or going out or spending money
working 12 hours per day doesn't just
seem like a no-brainer I actually look
forward to it as bad as it may sound I
actually get like really anxious when I
don't get any work done
but there's also one more reason why I
work 12 hours per day that I haven't
mentioned yet I'm really scared
they say that fear is the greatest
motivator and I think that's true
my biggest fear isn't failing or getting
criticized or making mistakes nope my
biggest fear you guys is that I wake up
one day old tired ugly down to my last
breath and I realize that I just didn't
do enough I didn't reach my full
potential and I found out working 12
hours per day gives me the right balance
between having the highest likelihood of
reaching my full potential and being
able to maintain my health by getting
enough sleep and that ladies and
gentlemen is why I work 12 hours per day
[Music]
so thank you so much for watching you
guys a few other notes I wants and
patent is that no I don't just work for
12 hours straight with how many breaks
I still take breaks I still eat I still
take my dogs for a walk and usually
spend telling my dad like once or twice
a week going out or something and as you
may have noticed this is a slightly
different style of view than what I
typically do and this one was inspired
by another youtuber named Nathaniel Zhu
he has some really good content which
inspired this video so let me know what
you think in the comments if I should
make more videos like this and what you
think about my home working 12 hours per
day you can like and subscribe for free
if you enjoyed this video you can also
just like and unsub if you want to do
that too if you want these 4k wallpapers
for your desktop and phone you can check
out with the link below for free thank
you so much for watching again you've
been awesome I've been Jake check out
these other videos of the YouTube guys
think that you would like and I'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]